Hello, everyone, and welcome
to Lecture 6 of CME 296.
So today is a very
exciting day because we'll
be talking about how to
train a model in practice,
a text-to-image
generation model.
And as you know, the
first half of this class
was all about preparing the
foundational theoretical
foundations for us to
be able to do that.
And in this second part,
we'll be really talking about
more the practical aspects,
and today will be no exception.
So as usual, before
we start, we're
going to just recap
what we saw last time.
So if you remember
last lecture, we
saw the main image
generation architectures.
And we started with
the big one, the UNet,
which was trendy up until 2022.
And we saw that
among the things we
wanted to see in an
image generation model,
we wanted the model that
was able to understand
the global structure
of an image,
also capture the local
details, able to receive
external signals, for
instance, a condition,
and be computationally
tractable.
And we saw that the UNet was
relying on an inductive bias.
Which was something that was
reflected by the convolution
operation, which is mimicking
how humans look at pictures.
And we saw that the unit was
composed of two main phases.
The first one is the
downsampling phases,
where we put an input, a
noisy latent, that we then
perform convolution operations
and downsampling operations
so that we can get a
bigger receptive field that
would enable us to have
a global understanding
of the input in the bottleneck.
So that was the first phase.
And then the second phase
with the upsampling phase,
which was composed of
upsampling operations,
for instance, the transpose
convolution, where
we were able to get back to the
dimension of interest, which
is the same dimension
as the input.
And we saw that there are these
copy-and-crop connections that
were allowing us to transport
the local details that we were
able to compute in the
downsampling phase and couple
that with the global
understanding that we had,
the global structure
understanding that we
had from the bottleneck.
So that was the UNet.
We saw that the UNet
was great, but the UNet
had a failure case,
which was that there
was no direct connection
between different local parts
of the image.
And for an example, such as
someone looking at oneself
in the mirror.
You need to be aware
of the local details
from two different
parts of the image.
So this was motivating us to
look at another architecture,
which is the diffusion
transformer, which was published
in 2022, late 2022, which
relies on the concept
of self-attention, where each
patch of the input latents
attends to one another, allowing
these direct connections
to form.
And as a result, we were able
to have this concern mitigated.
And we also saw a way
to inject conditions
into the architecture.
So we spend some time on the
adaptive layer normalization,
which was taking the
condition and the time step
as inputs that was modulating
the token embeddings
via this gates, shift,
and scale factors.
And we also saw that there were
very many variants, actually.
It was not just the
diffusion transformer,
there were many variants of
the diffusion transformer,
such as the multi-modal
diffusion transformer, which
is now more trendy, which was
looking at making the input
text as a standalone modality
that was being injected as input
as opposed to an afterthought
via the modulation,
mainly because the adaptive
layer norm was injecting
the condition across all patch
embeddings in a uniform way.
And we didn't want to have
that, so we also saw the MMD.
And of course,
these architectures
are not the only ones
that are out there.
There are many variations.
So hopefully, that
lecture was a lecture
that gave you the intuitive
tools to at least understand why
certain components are used.
All good on this?
So this was last lecture.
We also saw the timeline,
which I briefly mentioned here.
So UNet largely dominated
the early 2020s,
if I can say it like this.
And then the DIT-based models
are dominating the architectures
that are coming out nowadays,
from end of 2022 onwards.
And what are we
going to do today?
Today, we're going to focus
on practical applications,
on how we can actually train a
text to image generation model.
And I know so far we have
seen different components
of that overall system.
We've seen the
actual backbone that
is allowing us to denoise
the noise latents,
which is for instance
here a DIT-based model.
We've seen that there is
also another model involved,
the VAE, which is allowing us to
have a latent space in which we
can operate, which lowers
the computational burden
of our training process
and generation process.
And we've also seen that there
are multiple models we could
use that could embed
conditions that we would then
have as input.
So to be clear,
today we're going
to focus on how to train the
image generation model itself,
and we're not going to focus
on the VAE and the embedding
models.
So just for reference,
we will actually
dig into embedding models next
week with the multi-modal LLMs.
But I'm going to just
push it for next week.
More on that soon.
Cool.
So let's start.
And I just first want us to
look at this whole problem
at a very high level.
And in particular, look
at the overall process
that allows us to go
from an initialized model
to a model that is able
to work in production.
So the first step, we have
our image generation model.
We first teach it how to
generate images, any images.
This phase is typically
called the pre-training phase.
And it's quite
compute intensive.
It involves a lot of data and
a lot of work on the data side.
So that's number
one, and it's a phase
that all models go through.
Then we have a second stage
that is called the post-training
stage, where we take that
pre-trained model that already
knows how to generate images,
and we teach it how to generate
"good" images.
And we will see what good means.
We could also optionally
also personalize
our model to generate
specific kinds of images.
And we will see this
optional third step,
which is here called tuning.
And then at the end
of this lecture,
we'll also look at
how we can actually
make our model be able
to work in production
in an efficient way.
And here we will look
at distillation models
or distillation
methods, I should
say, that allow our model to
generate samples in fewer steps,
because we've seen that usually
these image generation models,
they're working in
an iterative fashion.
So you always have to have
one the initial noise as input
to get the let's
say vector field,
and then iterate on that
many times potentially.
And here we want to
shorten the amount of times
we need to do that so that we
can make this process just less
costly and reduce the latency,
which is typically what we care
about for production use cases.
Everyone good with
the big, big steps?
So we'll start with the first.
Even before starting, actually,
we'll be talking about the loss
that we will use for
our training process.
And I think you
already what the loss
is because we've spent the
first three lectures talking
about three different
perspectives on getting
to that stage.
So here, this part
is mainly around just
all agreeing on what
those losses are and see
what are the changes that happen
in practice to these losses
to make the training
process more optimized.
And you will see what I mean.
So first, I'm going to recap
what we saw during the three
first lectures.
So the first one, if you
recall, was diffusion with DDPM
where our thought process was
we take clean images that we
corrupt step by step,
so you have this xt that
is a function of the clean image
and the noise that you add.
And we saw that we could
derive a tractable loss,
and you end up
with a formula that
is allowing you to denoise
the noise with the formula
on the slides by
parameterizing a model that
is geared towards predicting the
noise to remove epsilon theta.
And here, the loss
is as follows.
So it's the expectation
of just the L2 distance
between your predicted
noise to remove
and the actual noise
that was added,
and it's an expectation
over the time steps,
the clean images that are
part of your training sets,
and then the noise that
is typically sampled
from a Gaussian distribution.
Then in Lecture 2, we had
this second perspective
of looking at the same problem,
which was, OK, in order
to recover clean
images, let's actually
look at where the
clean images are
by estimating the score, which
is acting like a compass.
And here we saw that there
was a stochastic differential
equation, way of putting
this, which was given by dx
is equal to some drift term
and some diffusion term,
along with the continuous noise,
which was the Wiener process.
So this was the forward process.
And then, the reverse
process was something
that was popping up the score.
And this just
highlighted the fact
that we needed to estimate
the score in order
to denoise into clean images.
And here, the last was an
expectation over the score
that you wanted to estimate
minus the actual score
of the noise distribution.
So that's the second
loss that we saw.
And then the third perspective,
which was lecture 3,
was the flow
perspective, where we
said that in order to go
from noise to our target
distribution, we're going
to interpret that problem
as a transport problem.
And here, we focused
on the velocity
or also known as
the vector field,
that could be used using an ODE
solver like the Euler method.
And we had a loss that was
regressing the vector field
by just taking two points.
So one from the target
distribution, x1,
and then x0 from the noisy
distribution, typically
a Gaussian distribution.
And we ended up with
this last function.
Now, one thing I want
to say, and maybe
I've said it some
time in the past,
nowadays, people mainly focus on
the flow-matching perspective.
So I just want us to all be
aligned that moving forward,
by default, we'll be
using the flow matching
loss as the default loss.
Does that sound good?
So let's look at this loss.
So here what we're
doing is we're
optimizing on the
parameter theta
such that we minimize
the loss on the slides
in particular by taking
the expectation over time
steps over data points in
the training data, so pdata,
and over noisy observations
that are part of a Gaussian
distribution.
And in particular,
we are taking--
so we were saying we
were taking t drawn
from a uniform distribution.
And I just want us to
pause on this statement
and see if this
actually makes sense.
But first, just as a
reminder, here by t we
level where t equals 0
corresponds to a lot of noise,
t equal to 1 means
no noise at all,
and t is somewhere in between
means a little bit noisy.
So I'm going to ask
you some questions.
So let's suppose we want to
figure out from an input that
is extremely noisy,
think of it as x0,
whether making a prediction
on where to go from x0
is an easy or a hard task.
And so I'm just going
to make our life easier.
So if you remember
the illustration
we had-- so we have the
noisy distribution that
is the one on the left
and then the target
distribution on the right.
So what we're saying is if
we sample a noisy latent that
is very noisy, is the
task of predicting
where to go an easy
task or a hard task?
Yeah, easy.
Do you want to say easy?
Yes, so it's indeed easy.
Now, why is it easy?
So at the very beginning,
the input that you have
is actually void
of all information.
You don't anything about
where you're going.
So what your model will
be incentivized to do
will be to just try
to predict if you
want the average direction,
where you need to go.
So regardless of how much
time you spend learning that,
it will just learn
roughly where to go,
which will be if you
want the mean of where
all the observations in your
target data distribution are.
So no matter how much time you
spend in that region of noise,
you will be incentivized to
predict the mean of where
all the observations are.
So that's why I say
it's an easy task.
So now, how about
if t is close to 1,
meaning that we're already very,
very advanced in the denoising
process and there is
almost no noise left?
Is it an easy task or a hard
task to where to go from there?
Hard?
Yeah, OK, so we have one heart.
Yep.
Easy again.
OK, so let's see.
So let's try to think.
So when t is close
to 1, what that means
is that the input xt is
already almost clean.
So we're almost there.
So what that means
is you only need
to make a few tweaks
to little details
to have a fully denoised image.
And in that sense, it
is actually an easy task
because you already have an
image that is almost clean
and so on.
The illustration, it corresponds
to if your observation is
already part of the
target data distribution,
and you just need to do a
small step towards having
your final observation.
OK, so let's do the last one.
How about if your input image is
not super, super, super noisy,
it's not almost clean, it's
somewhere in the middle?
Is the task easy?
Is the task of knowing
where to go easy or hard?
Yep.
Hard?
And same here?
OK, so yeah, you're
completely right.
And to illustrate the
point that you're saying,
we are indeed in
this space at a point
where we need to figure
out about where to go.
But even thinking about it
from an intuitive perspective,
let's assume that your target
distribution is composed
of images of teddy bears.
If you're in the
middle, then it means
that roughly what the body is
like, what the head is like,
you know a little bit
where the arms like,
but there's a lot of things
that you need to figure out
about where to place.
You need to figure out
what kind of texture
you want your teddy
bear to develop.
You need to put the eyes.
You need to put a
bunch of things.
And these are all hard
decisions that you
need to take at time steps that
are typically in the middle.
And for that reason,
t equal to 0.5
is a hard, hard
task for the model.
So if you remember,
what we saw was
that we were drawing our time
step when computing the loss
from a uniform distribution.
So what that means is
we're asking our model
to try to be good at predicting
the target as many times
for easy tasks as much
as for hard tasks.
And this is the reason why,
in practice, people actually
do not sample the time step
from a uniform distribution.
They actually sample from
another distribution,
which we're going to see in
a second, that emphasizes
on middle steps more
than it emphasizes
on either the early or
the late, late steps.
And the distribution that
people in general use
typically is called the
logit-normal distribution.
So the formula on the
slide may look scary,
but it's actually quite simple.
So what we're saying is--
so first of all, I'm going
to define what logit means.
So the logit of a
quantity-- so let's suppose
the logit of our time step t.
--is defined as the log of
t over 1 minus t as follows.
And so t is between 0 and 1.
So if t is between 0
and 1, then logit of t
is anywhere between minus
infinity to plus infinity.
And what we're saying
is if we sample
x from a normal distribution,
which is between minus infinity
to plus infinity, then if we
express t as a function of x,
which--
I'm looking at the time,
we will probably not do.
You will have something like
this, which is just a sigmoid.
And that quantity will
have a distribution
that will be really
centered in the middle.
So you may ask me, "Well, why do
you not sample directly t from
a normal distribution?"
Maybe it's a question you ask.
But the reason why you don't do
that is the normal distribution
is a distribution that
can take any values,
and you only want
values between 0 and 1.
So that mathematical trick
is just a way for you
to guarantee that
in between 0 and 1
because here the sigmoid
is between 0 and 1.
Does that make sense?
OK, great.
I just want this formula
or this distribution
to not seem like it's
coming out of nowhere.
So the good thing
with this distribution
is you can tweak the way
the distribution is shaped.
So you can play with the mean
and the standard deviation,
so you can shift it towards the
time steps that you care about.
So for instance, if
you in your use case
care about the later
steps, you can do that.
And so that is the reason why
people use that distribution.
But I'm not done
with time steps.
There's another thing I
want to talk to you about.
So we're talking
about noise levels,
but what we actually
care about is how much
noise is perceived by yourself.
So if you take the same
image, one in low resolution
and the other one
in high resolution--
and if you apply the same amount
of noise, which, from the slide,
I hope you can see, that the one
on the left, the low resolution
one, feels more noisy
than the one on the right.
So same image,
different resolution,
but same noise level.
The one on the left feels more
noisy than the one on the right.
So something tells
you that you also
need to take that into
account in some way.
So right now, we're not taking
that into account, but not
for long.
So you will see that
in papers, there
is this concept of
time step shifting
as a function of resolution,
where the idea is to rescale
the noise level in a way that
reflects the perceived noise
that you see.
And so I just want to pause
on this concept for a second.
Why would you perceive a
low-resolution image would
be more noisy than a
high-resolution one
for the same noise level?
Why would you have to do that?
Or why would you think that?
Well, there is one
thing with images,
which is that they have a
lot of spatial correlation.
Meaning for a given
pixel, you have--
you are very likely to have
pixels around it that have
the same value or same color.
And so remember that
when you add your noise,
you're adding Gaussian
noise with mean 0.
So what that means is if you
have very few pixels, when
you're in low resolution,
then if the pixel that
is responsible for,
let's say, the color
that characterizes how good
your image looks, let's
say, at a particular angle--
if that one gets noised, then
you're losing that information.
You're not able
to see it anymore.
But in the
high-resolution case, you
have multiple pixels
surrounding that region.
So even if one gets
noise, the other one
gets noise the other way because
remember that the mean should
be equal to 0, the mean
of the noise, added noise,
should be equal to
0, you will still
have an average value that
will reflect the underlying
pixels much more compared
to the low-resolution case.
So for that reason, I hope
the statement that I'm making,
which is, for a
given noise level,
things feel more noisy for
low-resolution images compared
to high-resolution ones--
I hope that one is intuitive.
I'm going to pause for a second.
Does everyone agree
with my statement?
Yep?
OK, so there is, again, a very
scary formula on the slides.
The reason why there
is just to show you
how people shift time
steps in practice.
So I would first want us to
look at the chart on the right.
So you see tn and tm.
So here, let's assume you have
two images, one of resolution n
and the other one of resolution
m, where n is smaller than m.
So here for a
given tn, you would
want to have a higher tm because
for a low-resolution image,
for a given noise level,
you would want that noise
level to be higher for
the high-resolution image,
for the perceived
noise to be the same.
So that is what this
formula is saying.
But I know it's not
intuitive, so what we'll do
is we'll take 10 minutes
to try to understand
what that is about.
So the formula on the
slide is all about
reflecting the change in
uncertainty of pixel values
that are noised under
different resolutions.
So let's assume that
we have an image,
so you can think of
it as this, with--
OK, I'm being quick.
So you have, let's say,
height and some width.
And let's say that n--
so let's say m is this one.
And let's say you have a
smaller image with, let's say,
h, little h, and little w,
and n is equal to h times w.
I'm just saying that n is
a lower resolution than m.
That's just what I want to say.
So here, what we
want to do is to try
to quantify the
uncertainty of what
the underlying pixel values
are in the case where
we have noise for both cases.
So what I propose to do is to
just assume that these images--
let's assume that they all
have a certain value as pixels.
So pixels have three channels.
Let's assume here that
we have only one channel,
one value by component.
So here, let's assume that
each of these is, let's say,
equal to some value
c that is constant.
So far so good?
So let's assume that
for a given let's
say index i that tells you about
where you are in the image,
and for a given noise level
t, the value at that index
is something that is
given as a function of C,
the value of your pixel,
and the amount of noise
that you're adding to it.
So here I just need to
put the noise level.
So I told you in
lecture one that people
use different conventions
for time steps.
And it just happens
that the formula here
and the paper here, they
used the reverse convention
when it comes to time steps.
And in particular, they used
t equals 0, means clean, and t
equals 1, means noise,
which is the opposite
of what usually people do.
But in order for us to
be consistent and end up
at the same formula,
we will just
assume that is the convention
that we're going to use.
So here, what we're going
to say is it's 1 minus tc
plus t epsilon.
Does everyone agree with me?
So this is the value of the
noise pixel at the noise level
t.
So here epsilon is drawn
from a normal distribution.
And so what can we
say about this one?
So we assume that this
quantity is a constant,
but we don't what that quantity
is when we look at an image.
So our goal here is to
quantify the uncertainty
if we were to estimate
c, which is a constant.
So what I'm going to do
is to try to quantify
the uncertainty of c.
So here, just because
we have n elements,
so m here and n
here n elements, I'm
just going to leverage
the fact that we
have this n elements to take the
average over all pixel values.
So I'm going to sum
over, let's say,
i my index, that's between
1 and the number of pixels,
of the zi(t).
And I'm going to call
this zt bar for average.
So here, this thing is a
constant, so it doesn't move.
And this thing just gets--
so here, I'm going to write
this here plus the average.
So I'm going to put the t here.
The sum of y from--
sorry, sorry.
The sum of I from 1 to n of
the epsilons, which are--
as a function of i.
Because the noise here
is different from one
pixel to another.
So here what I wrote is that
the average value of a pixel
is 1 minus t times
c plus t over n
of the sum of the noise values.
So you're going to
see why I did that.
So here, I just want
to remember our--
to remind you of our objective.
Our objective is to quantify
the uncertainty in estimating c.
So I want us to first
see that zt bar is
equal to a constant plus a
sum of independent Gaussian
variables.
So what you can see
about-- what you
can say about this quantity
is that its mean is
1 minus t times c.
And its variance-- let's see.
So t over n is a constant.
So the variance of a constant
is just the constant squared.
And then the variance
of each epsilon i is 1,
and you're adding n of them.
So it's n times 1, which
is t squared over n.
OK, great.
So why am I doing all of this?
I just want to remind all of us
that what we know-- what we want
is to estimate the
uncertainty of C.
So what is a good
estimator for C?
So C-- here, we
see that zt bar is
equal to minus C times C plus
something where the mean is 0.
So a good estimate of C could be
1 over 1 minus t times zt bar.
And what we want to quantify is
the uncertainty in estimating c.
So what is the uncertainty
around estimating c.
So this thing is a constant.
So the variance of
a constant is just--
so sorry, the
variance of a factor
in front of something else
is the constant squared
times the variance of this
one, which is t squared over n.
So what we're saying is
that the standard deviation
of our estimate is equal to the
square root of the variance,
which is t over 1 minus t
times 1 over square root of n.
OK, so what does that mean?
That means that the
uncertainty that we have around
determining what the pixel
value, underlying pixel value,
is a function of 1 over the
square root of the resolution.
So as we increase
the resolution n,
that uncertainty gets smaller.
And so in order to get
that derivation, which
I don't think I will do,
it is just some math,
you would just equal
that uncertainty for n.
So it's t under
subscript n here.
And you do the same for m.
So you get exactly-- so the
noise level at time step--
for resolution m
will be as follows.
And the goal that we have
is to determine the time
step for resolution m such that
the uncertainty of determining
the pixel value is the same.
So you just need to take
these two quantities
and just say that
they need to be equal,
and you find tm as
a function of tn.
Does that make sense?
So the low-level derivation
is not that important.
What is important
is just the mindset,
which is that here we want to
shift the time step for higher
resolution, such that
we match this perceived
noise that we have.
And so hopefully, when you
take a look at that formula,
you're not thinking, "OK,
where does that come from?"
OK, cool.
So I think we're done
with the time steps.
Any questions on this?
Yep.
What is c again?
Yes.
So the question is,
What is c again?
So this was actually
a toy example
that we had where
we said let's assume
that we have an image where all
the pixel values are constants,
all equal to c.
So c is the value of the
pixel that is across all
our image in this toy example.
And the only problem with
c-- we know it's constant,
but we don't what c is because
we have noised that image.
And this whole derivation
is about quantifying
our uncertainty of what c is
if we were to estimate it.
And what we said was that we
could quantify the uncertainty
through this standard deviation.
And what we said was,
depending on the resolution
at which you're operating, that
uncertainty is higher or lower.
And in particular,
that uncertainty
is lower as the
resolution gets higher.
And this is all because you can
actually perform your estimation
by averaging across
all pixel values, which
are getting bigger and bigger
when the resolution increases.
Does that make sense?
OK, perfect.
Yeah, yep.
So the question is, we said that
the diffusion process is taking
place in the latent space, so m
and n are in the latent space?
Yes.
Yep.
OK, perfect.
Let's move on.
We're done with the time steps.
Now we're going to the
next training trick
that I wanted to
talk about, which
is helping our model with
learning representations faster.
And how do we want to do that?
So here, the whole idea is to
leverage the representation
that some already pre-trained
encoders have learned
and incorporate that,
and incentivize our model
to match that representation.
So in other words, it's as if
you want to learn about a topic,
and I come and get you
a book about that topic.
So you can learn
faster about the topic,
so it's exactly
the same mindset.
So here, REPA is the
name of the method.
It stands for
Representation Alignment.
And it consists of
coupling your loss
with a loss that reflects how
similar the representations
that you're obtaining within
your diffusion transformer
is with respect to what the
pre-trained encoder is giving
you.
So that's what REPA is about.
So let's go step by step.
Here, we mentioned
the L loss for REPA,
but we have not seen
what that loss is.
So we're going to see now.
So here what we're saying is
in the diffusion transformer,
you have several layers.
So what you're saying is you're
taking the encoded output
of a given layer.
So let's call that ht.
And here n, I believe,
represents the patch,
let's say, for a given patch n.
And let's project
that on a space where
we can compare the equivalent
clean patch representation
from the pretrained encoder,
and then have a similarity
operation between the two.
So in other words, we will
be penalizing our model
for having a projection of the
encoded output of a given patch.
That is, noise we will penalize
our model from this being
dissimilar from
the representation
given by the pre-trained encoder
of that same patch, but cleaned.
So why do we do that?
So as I mentioned,
we're giving a book
to someone who's
learning about a topic
so that they can learn faster.
And that's exactly what happens.
So what we're seeing
with this strategy
is that it speeds up training
significantly, so here
on the order of 18 times.
So this graph
represents some measure
of how good your images are
as a function of the training
iteration.
And what the
authors did was just
try out a bunch of different--
they tried a bunch of things.
So they tried different models.
They tried different layers.
They tried-- so they did
a lot of ablation studies.
One of the things
that they saw was
if you were to perform that loss
on the embedding from earlier
layers, then you actually
get better results.
And I just want to pause
on that statement for a bit
just to understand
why that is the case.
So our diffusion
transformer gets
to compute a prediction
of where it wants to go.
And in that sense,
the later layers
may actually involve
more local details
rather than a semantic
representation
of where you want to go.
And so here that
pre-trained encoders,
some of them, what
they're good at
is representing things in a
semantically meaningful way.
And so one can
understand these facts
by saying that, OK, we actually
want the representation
from a layer that is supposed
to output something that
is semantically
meaningful to align
with a semantic or semantically
meaningful representation.
I just wanted to vocalize
a possible interpretation.
And then the last
thing I will say
is that an interesting thing
is that the bigger your model,
the faster or the more benefits
you have from this method.
Cool.
And the REPA was
published in 2024,
but it is a technique
that I have personally
seen in a lot of new papers,
so worth keeping in mind.
And that is concluding the
first preliminary parts.
So now we're going
to first start
the first step of the lifecycle,
training lifecycle, which
is pre-training.
And so as a reminder,
in this first step,
the goal is to teach our model
how to generate just images.
And so here there
is a lot of work
that goes into
what kind of images
you want your model
to learn from.
And so I just have
this one slide,
which is coming from-- so
it's an image from the Quinn
technical report,
which just tells you
that this is a very
time-consuming work
that's involves data pipeline
with a bunch of filtering,
different resolutions,
cleaning, and so on.
So I just have one slide
to illustrate this,
but it's a very
time consuming step.
So just know that this is an
important part of the process.
There is a concept that I
want to talk to you about,
which is called
curriculum learning, which
is about teaching your model on
things in a progressive manner
on the scale of difficulty.
So in other words,
here, what we want
is to teach first our model
on doing the easy things
before doing the hard things.
And this is a practice
that is typically something
that people do as this just
helps the model learn better.
And so here, by "easy" I mean
low-resolution images that are
of very easy aspect
ratio, so fixed square.
You can think of that.
And then the input text
is simple and short,
so for instance, a teddy bear.
And then the hard
part is if you want
to predict something that
is of high resolution,
different aspect ratios.
It's not a square anymore.
And then, your prompt can be
much, much more complicated,
such as the one on the slides.
And now you may ask me, well,
how would you handle images
of different resolutions?
And so I want us to remember
that the default architectures
these days are DIT-based.
And in DIT, what you do is you
divide your input into patches
where each patch is
equivalent to some embedding.
And so what happens
is for low resolution,
you will have a certain
number of patches,
some number of tokens.
And for high resolution, you
will just have more tokens.
Yes, exactly.
So yeah, that's exactly that.
It's as if it was large context.
And if you remember
the length t will
be i, which is the
dimension of an input.
So if it's a squared
over p squared.
So that's the order of
magnitude to have in mind.
I will go ahead and move on to
the second step of the training
lifecycle, which is
the post training step.
And so here what
we want to do is
to teach our model on how
to generate good images.
Now you may tell me, "Well,
what does good mean?"
Well, you have, of
course several angles,
but I'll talk about
two main names
that you will see out there.
The first one is called
continued training, CT,
which is around teaching your
model on a bunch of other things
that you may care about
in your task of interest.
So I'll give you an example.
So let's suppose you have a
model that has been pre-trained
on a bunch of nature
images, and cars, and so on,
but what you want to do
is to have a model that
generates images of teddy bear.
Well, what you'll
do here is you will
have a dataset of
what you care about,
and here that is teddy bears.
And you will just continue
your training on that data set.
So that part, you
can think of it
as focusing on increasing
your knowledge.
Then you have another category
of post-training methods, which
are called supervised
fine-tuning.
Same thing, but
here the mindset is
to focus on the behavior
of your model as opposed
to increasing the knowledge.
So in that case, what that means
is generating an image that
is more aesthetically pleasing,
that has better lighting,
or that just follows
the text better.
So these are the kinds of
dimensions that you care about.
And up until now,
we've only seen
how to teach our
model on what to do,
but we have not taught our
model on what not to do.
And that is the objective of
the second category of methods,
which is preference tuning
methods, where for a given
prompt, you may have two images
where one of those images
is something that you want to
happen more than another one.
So here I will illustrate an
example of the left image, which
is an image of a teddy
bear reading, very high
resolution, good lighting,
and aesthetically pleasing,
and the one on the right,
which is not as aesthetically
pleasing.
And what you want to do is
to incentivize your model
to generate an
image that is more
aligned with human preferences.
So here the thumbs
up and thumbs down
are typically either human
ratings or some measure
that you can obtain
with some model
that we will talk
about next lecture.
But you will need to have some
measure of pairwise comparison
or listwise comparison
of different images.
And in this case, the left image
being better than the right one.
So how do you do that?
So before we move
further, I just
want to say that the field
is still a developing field,
and that next to it, there's
also the text field, the LLM
field, that has been growing.
And so one observation
is that you
will find the same
kinds of techniques
that are used in
the LLM space be
adapted for the text-to-image
generation space.
And that is something
that I'm going to show you
in the slides that will follow.
So the first method that
is around tuning your model
to incentivize generating
images that are more
aligned with human
preferences is a method called
reward feedback learning.
So I'll go step by step
into what that does.
So as I mentioned, what you
do is you take a prompt,
and then you have a bunch of
images related to that prompt.
And what you do is you try to
get some sense of which one
is better than the other.
So you can either
get pairwise ratings
or even list wise ratings.
So for instance, A is better
than B, than C, et cetera.
And from there, the idea
is to train a reward model
that takes in a
prompt and an image,
and that gets you a
score that tells you
how good that image was
with respect to the score,
or how good that image was
with respect to the prompt.
And so here we will not
go through the math.
So in case you're
interested, we actually
have a whole lecture on that
in our sister class, CME 295.
But long story short is that you
can use a pairwise loss based
on formulation called the
Bradley-Terry formulation
and train a model that
does that for you.
So at the end of this step,
you get a reward model
that takes in a prompt,
that takes in an image,
and that tells you how good
that image was to this prompt.
So what you care
about is to tune
your text-to-image
generation model
to produce images
that are higher
rewards, because the reward
model that you trained
is something that hopefully
aligns with human preferences.
So if the reward model
says that one is good,
then hopefully, it's
something that is aligned
with what the human would say.
And what you want is to
train your image generation
model in order to produce
images that are higher rewards.
So there is some math involved,
but at a very high level,
what we do is we take
the noisy latent,
we predict or generate an image
for which we have the reward.
But in this case, the good
thing is that we have the model.
We have the reward model.
It is a reward model that
we have at our disposal.
So it is actually something
that is differentiable.
And so here, you
can back propagate
the loss or the
objective that you have,
which is to maximize those
rewards back into your image
generation model in order
to incentivize that model
to produce images that
are higher rewards.
So that is reward
feedback learning.
The second method
I will introduce
is called Flow Group Reward
Policy Optimization a.k.a.
Flow-GRPO.
So for those of you who
are also in the LLM field,
you may have heard
the term GRPO a lot
during the past year or so.
And so here, the
idea is to leverage
that algorithm in the
case of image generation.
So in a very similar
fashion, what you do is you
take a look at images that
are generated by your image
generation model, and in
this case, what you want
is for a given prompt to have a
diverse set of generated images.
So it's going a little
bit into the details,
but the authors are
framing this via an SDE
that increases the diversity
of images that are generated,
so this is all so
that we can have,
for a given prompt,
a diverse set
of images that are generated.
And from there, compute
relative rewards,
meaning you pass
each prompt along
with each image to some
black-box reward model,
and it tells you whether or
not that is a good image.
And what you do is you
compute a relative measure
of how good that image was
with respect to the other image
in your group.
So that's why this
method is called
group Reward Policy
Optimization,
is because you
actually compute--
so an advantage, that's
the technical term,
which is the reward relative
to the reward in your group.
And then based on that,
you update the policy which
is your image generation model.
And so one thing
that I want to say,
and it's true for all of
these reward-based approaches,
is your reward is not
necessarily something that
is fully aligned with
what you care about.
And so you can have a problem
of reward hacking, where
your model is being
updated too much in a way
to optimize the reward
that is not perfectly
aligned with what you want.
And so in order to have a
way to mitigate that issue,
you typically have an
extra term in your loss.
And so here in the slide
it's kind of small,
but it's a KL divergence term
between the policy that you're
training on and the old policy.
So it's just a
way for you to not
have iterations, updates that
are too far from the old model.
And the last one I will
mention, and here I'm
sorry for this big
formulas, but I
couldn't find a good
illustration for this one.
So this one is
called Diffusion DPO.
And Diffusion DPO is
the diffusion equivalent
of DPO, which is a supervised
method used in the LLM world
to tune the weights
of your model
with respect to
human preferences.
And here, what you need to take
away from these three lines
of equations is that you want
to incentivize your model
to predict cities associated
with "winning" images.
You want to
incentivize your model,
doing a better job
at predicting those,
and you want to incentivize
your model to do a worse job
at predicting velocities
of the "bad" images.
So if you do that,
you're going to have
a higher chance of having the
winning images be generated
and a lower chance of having
your model generate the worse
images from being generated.
Does this part make sense?
So we have these three
lines of equations.
You can stare at
it after the class.
It's something
that also tells you
that we want the model to be
better at predicting velocities
of winning images, and
worse at predicting
loss velocity of losing images.
So yeah, so this is what this
loss is telling you to do.
OK, great.
So there is one last
thing I want to tell you.
We want to make
our images better.
And I want you to
tell me, or I'm
asking if you would know
what kind of prompts
would lead to that kind of
image at this point in time,
in the training, if
you were to guess.
So here on the left, you
have a beautiful image
of a Teddy bear reading a book.
So the question here is what
prompt do you want to put?
Anyone wants to try?
Can be creative.
You think it's a trick question.
So I'm going to just
for the sake of time,
tell you what the prompt was.
So it's actually a
truncated prompt,
and I'll just read
the first few words.
So "A warm, intimate indoor
reading scene featuring a plush
teddy bear as a central
object, and it talks about how
the objects are, how
the lighting is."
And it's actually maybe four
times what is on the slide.
So the point here is that
these alignment methods
allow us to have much
greater control on what we
want the output image to be.
And there is,
therefore, a mismatch
between what we teach
the model and what
users tell to the model.
Because let's be
honest, you and I,
if we want to create an
image of a teddy bear,
we'll just say "a teddy
bear reading a book."
But we want something
that looks like this.
So there needs to be
something in between that
is able to prompt our
model well in a way that
will generate beautiful images.
And there is a method called
prompts enhancement, which
will take a given user
input and transform it
into a very elegant,
long, detailed prompt that
would be similar to
the kinds of prompts
that the model has
been trained on.
And so this is all for us to
have a beautiful image based
on a prompt that is in
distribution, if you want,
and that is leveraging the
capabilities of the model.
So I just want to
take a pause here.
So I know I'm doing a lot
of metaphors comparisons,
but let's try to recap all
the steps we've been through
by taking the following analogy.
So let's assume that our
image generation model is us,
is similar to us actually
learning how to cook.
So pre-training is about
learning how to generate images.
So here just learn about the
different kinds of foods.
Post-training is about learning
how to generate "good" images.
So here, what does good mean?
So these are examples
that we give you,
so supervised fine tuning
and continued training.
Continued training
is new knowledge.
So here, it's as if I was
reading about recipes.
So I read about recipes
of how to make good food.
And then supervised fine-tuning
is about the aesthetics,
it's about the prompts,
the instruction following.
And so here, I'm just making
sure that the food looks great.
The delivery is good.
And then you have the
preference tuning stage
where you want to make sure
to do more of the things
that you may like
rather than not.
And in this food
analogy case, you
have an inspector, food
inspector that comes,
and you cook several
times the same dish.
And inspector just
tastes how good
each of the dishes
that you prepared
was and it just tells
you which one was better.
And you update your way
of cooking based on that.
And this prompt enhancement
thing is the same as you being
in a restaurant and a customer
walking in and telling you,
"I want meat."
But for you, you just know
medium-rare kind of meat
with a pinch of salt and so on.
So you will have a waiter
between the customer
and yourself that will
rephrase the customer's request
in a way that aligns with
what you have learned.
And this is exactly what
prompts enhancement is.
I hope this made sense.
And with that, let's go to the
third stage of the training
lifecycle, which is tuning.
So as I mentioned, tuning is
about personalizing your model
for a special use case
that you care about.
And so here, the method that
I want to talk to you about
is a method that you may
have seen on the internet
because a lot of people
have been using it.
It's called DreamBooth.
And the idea is that you
have something of interest,
let's say a specific
teddy bear, that you
want to have in the
images that you generate.
You don't want any teddy bear.
You want that
specific teddy bear.
So what you want is to
personalize your model
to generate images of that
very specific teddy bear.
So here's what you would do.
What you would do
is taking your model
and then having a few images
of that very specific teddy
bear that you have, take
images of that teddy bear
with different poses,
and train your model
to generate that teddy bear
based on a prompt that relies
on a rare token, that is here
bracket V. That will teach
your model to associate
that specific person/object
reference with that token.
So you do that.
So let's say you do that.
Do you see an example or
something that can go wrong.
If you train your model to
generate these images based
on that prompt?
OK, let's assume
you just do that.
Yep.
So the answer is it's
not diverse enough.
So I think you're very,
very-- you're touching exactly
the problem that we have at
hand, which is that you will
specialize your model
too much into generating
that and actually forgetting
the kinds of concepts,
the kinds of images it was
able to produce before.
And so for that reason,
so it's a great answer
for that reason, what you
want is to also make sure
that your model does not lose
the ability that it had before.
And so that's why what you
would want to do is to have some
reference of text-to-image pairs
that it was able to generate
successfully, that you would
also tell it to generate
successfully and combine the
two into a loss that tells you,
"I want to generate images
with that specific teddy bear,
but also preserving the
performance that I had
in the past."
And this is called the
prior preservation loss.
That's second term.
So when you do that training--
and so yeah.
So you prevent overfitting.
So when you do that training,
what you're able to do
is to use that rare special
token that you have trained
your model on and then generate
new images in specific settings.
So here the special token
teddy bear attending CME 296,
so this is how teddy
bear would look like.
So that method is great,
and what we're doing
is updating our model and
in particular the model
weights in order to reflect
what we want to generate.
Well, the problem is your
model can be quite big.
It can be as big as
billions of parameters.
I believe the biggest
text-to-image models
that are out there are in the
order of tens of billions,
the open-source ones.
And so you would not want to
update all the weights, which
is the reason why
there is a method that
is very commonly used in the LLM
world, which is also something
that people use in this
instance, which is called LoRA,
and stands for
Low-Rank Adaptation.
And what this method
does is instead
of training all the
weights of your model, what
it does is it only trains
a fraction by considering
that the weights of your model
are the weights of the base
model, plus two
low-rank matrices.
And the reason why it's
called low-rank adaptation
is because it leads to A
times B, that is low rank.
And so when you do
that, it turns out
that you can preserve
most of the performance
but train that with a
fraction of the cost.
So you will see methods that
are called "DreamBooth + LoRA."
And that is what it is about.
And I want to talk
about the pros
and the cons of this approach.
So the pro is--
the good thing is if
you want to generate
thousands and thousands of
images of your teddy bear, well,
you can do that.
And the results are
pretty high fidelity.
They match pretty
well the details
that are in the input images.
But the con here
is if you need--
or if you need to do that
for a lot of special cases,
well, you need to absorb the
training costs, which is pretty
time consuming and costly.
And also, it's something
that you cannot really reuse
if, for instance, you want
something else in your images.
And I would just conclude by
saying that this approach is
great if you're in
a use case where
you need to generate many,
many, many, many images of one
specific subject, or
person, or object.
And with that, I'll
give it to Shervin.
Thank you, Afshin.
So we're going to
continue together
on that note of
efficiency and looking
at distillation
techniques which aim
at preserving some
of the high quality
that we were able to
develop with these models,
but at a lower cost.
So all of these methods produce
state-of-the-art images,
but in real life, you might be a
user that uses a service that is
high volume.
So the provider doesn't
have an incentive
to spend a lot of
money on each query.
So you don't want typically to
have 1,000 steps to generate
a single image.
Similarly, if you're
in a business setting,
you want to achieve
a given goal,
and your goal is not
necessarily to be
the best, but just good enough.
And then that
trade-off between good
in terms of quality
and cost is something
that you're going
to be interested in.
And then you can cite
other applications
where real-time
properties are important.
So this is why it's
worth investigating
techniques that are fast.
And then all of these are, of
course, linked to properties
that we care about
as everyday users.
So we don't want to
spend a lot, and we
don't want to spend
resources inefficiently.
And if I was to tell
you about distillation
in the traditional world--
so you would typically see
something that looks like this.
You have a teacher
model that is big
and a student model that is
typically of a smaller size.
And you both want to
predict the same outputs.
And here, for example, so
I'm borrowing these slides
from CME 295, where
we wanted to distill
some of the knowledge on
next token prediction.
So what is important in
this distillation technique
is truly the shape of the
distribution that is learned.
And you can see that you can
get away with smaller models,
directly anchoring
on it and then
producing a level of quality
that is almost just as high.
So just to give a
quantitative example,
you may think of a
BERT and DistilBERT,
where you save
quite a bit, I think
60%, half of the
parameters, roughly,
and you retain 97%
of the performance.
So this is something that
we are interested in doing
as well here.
So in the LLM
world, for example,
you would do so with the KL
divergence between the two.
So here, the loss
says if we assume
that the teacher
distribution is a true one,
how bad is it to approximate
it with a student one?
And this is how you perform
your loss optimization process
with that kind of mindset.
But here in the image
world, well, you
can try to reduce the
size of the student model.
And it typically leads
to much worse quality.
And then you have
another knob that you
have as a low-hanging fruit
that people typically tune,
which is not the model size
but more the number of steps.
So you might remember from the
first lecture that, for example,
in diffusion you have,
let's say 1,000 steps.
Similarly, in the flow matching
setting that afshin mentioned,
we were considering
here, you typically
have more than one step.
And you would want
to make it one,
so that just a single pass
gives you what you want.
So here, we were not going
to be doing typically
KL divergence between
distribution over tokens,
but these kind of
loss that regresses
the output with respect
to the teacher output
is something that
you are going to see.
So one way of doing it is
with the mean squared error.
We're going to see other
techniques as well.
And I just want us
to do this thought
exercise of approximating in
one step directly the teacher
output.
So the issue is that it's
too hard because you can--
so just to take the analogy
that Afshin was taking
last week regarding
the painter, it's
as if you ask a painter to
paint a beautiful piece of art
and then ask the
students to do exactly
the same with a single stroke.
So it's way too much information
packed for a single forward step
to capture all at once.
So you need a more granular
subsequence of steps
intuitively.
And this is what the spirit
of progressive distillation
is, where we take steps and ask
the students to work on problems
that are of approximate
constant difficulty,
and we iterate until we have a
model that does what we want.
So in other words,
the formulation
here is that we want the number
of total steps to go from big T
to 1.
So here the method
is as follows,
every time you try to
do what you were doing
in half the number of steps.
So I want you to make
a thought experiment
for a second
between Afshin and I
and not suppose
that we are twins,
but instead, we
are a tuple of size
n of identical brothers, more
precisely of size log2 of number
of steps.
And here progressive
distillation
would be Afshin, for
example, being the master
painter for the first step.
And every two strokes I would
paint one stroke, and so on.
And then once the
process finishes,
I would be the master
painter, and then
the next identical brother
would be the student.
So every two strokes
that I paint,
he would paint one stroke,
so that at the end,
you reach what you
want in a single step.
So just to give a visual
representation of what
we have learned here--
so you can see this
as secant lines
that you draw in the
space at every halving
of the number of steps,
which is a simple problem
to take in isolation.
And then when you
do that iteratively,
you reach the end goal.
So looking at the results
here, the good thing
about this technique
is that you can select
the number of
function evaluations
that you're ready
to spend, and you
have an association
with the end result.
So of course, if you
spend more steps,
you're going to
have better quality,
but you have this
level of granularity.
And you see that you typically
have better performance
if you were to compare
an equal number of steps,
for example, in a deterministic
technique like DDIM,
like we had seen in the
first lecture, which is nice.
But here, one thing
that we're doing
is that no matter
how hard the path
to getting to the
clean image is,
we're just taking it as a given.
We're not saying, OK, let's
to make the problem simpler.
We're just taking the
problem as hard as it is
and we're trying
to work around it.
And if you recall the third
lecture on flow matching,
there is something that
we wish for that we
might be able to
realize, which is
the reflow technique that
helps in straightening paths
in the space.
So maybe we could
make use of it.
And this is what the paper
called "InstaFlow" does.
So it follows up on this
idea of rectified flow
that we had seen at
the third lecture.
So it does apply this method.
And then on top of it, it
adds a layer of distillation
to further solidify
the fact that we
can get to the results
in a single step.
So just to give you a recap on
what reflow was, so you had--
so let's say you sample
from the easy distribution
and then you integrate your
ODE to get to the sample.
Then you take these
pairs of input-outputs
and then you fit a new model,
like a new model in it.
And what you get is
straighter path, typically,
which allows you
to take less Euler
steps to get to the answer.
But I have a question for you.
Let's say the problem
is not totally straight,
would you be inclined
to do more reflow steps?
So it's a trick question.
So the answer is if you
do more reflow steps,
then you introduce
discretization errors
in your pairs.
So the answer is typically no.
And this is why what is
pretty convenient to do
is to give the task
of still integrating
that ODE to some teacher model
and then have a student fit
directly on that output.
So this is what the
distillation step does.
And then one interesting
fact is that we use--
so this concept of
distance between what
the teacher predicts and
what the student gets to.
So you have this
concept of warm-up,
of using a simple
distance metric like MSE.
But we have seen in
the previous lecture
that MSE is not great to give
a meaningful interpretation
into whether the quality
of the image is good,
because it focuses on the
specific value of each pixel
instead of the meaning
of the feature,
which is why this method
uses the second loss
formulation called LPIPS,
Learned Perceptual Image Patch
Similarity.
And here, you make the image
pass through a pre-trained model
with frozen weights,
and then you
compare the L2 distance
between the feature
maps instead over L layers.
And this is what we just said.
And then you see in practice,
that the first reflow step gives
you most of the
straightening behavior,
so you meaningfully-- you
do not have an incentive
to do more of them.
And in terms of results,
you see that you exceed
the performance of whether--
of the fact that you add this
additional distillation step
is better than just doing a
reflow and having a single step.
So it's the InstaFlow 0.9B
versus the line just above that
shows that.
And yeah.
So one thing that is
tough with InstaFlow
is that every time
you do a reflow,
it's an expensive process.
So you need to do some
pre work, which is--
like the cost you
have to pay here.
And we're wondering
if there is something
we could do better when it comes
to the path that are drawn.
Is there some information that
we could give to the student
instead of making the problem
simpler from the first place?
But before I move on
to the next mindset
that I wanted to mention, I just
wanted to pause for a second
and see if there
is any questions.
Yep.
The question is, Why wouldn't
you force straight path
in the pre-training?
You already do that, because you
select a random noise at random
and then a target point, and
then you draw a straight line.
But the thing is, these
pairings, they're not optimal.
So when you sample randomly--
and then the fact that you
don't have these straight lines
is not an intended
design, but it's
a consequence of this MSE loss.
So the reflow procedure
is our way to remedy that,
and there is no way to do that
as early as the first train.
OK, awesome.
So I'm slightly late--
so I'm going to go through
this next idea of leveraging
local properties
to train a better
student with this notion of
consistency models, which
has an interesting property
of looking at paths that
are deterministic with
a mapping that maps
every point of that path
to the end goal, such that
no matter where you
are on that path,
if you train your model
to predict the end image,
then you can make
the jump as early
as when you are in the noise
in the noise distribution.
So just putting a picture
here with our teddy bears
and the flow matching case,
if you have such a property,
then every point on a given
green line would map to x1.
And the way to do so is twofold.
So you can either do it with
so-called consistency training,
where you sample a
clean image and then you
noise it at some level
t, and you noise it
at level t plus delta t.
And what you do is that you
pass it through your model
and try to make them
match to the same value.
So this is one way of doing so.
There is a second
way that leverages
this teacher-student
relationship, where denoising
is not something that you
would artificially do,
but you would ask
a teacher model
to do denoising, which
reflects properties
that it has learned
in the feature space,
and then you ask a student
model to make predictions that
are consistent to each other.
So here, you might say,
"OK, very well, Sherwin.
But if you only force these
representations to be consistent
with each other, you could
well have a student that says,
OK, don't worry, I
will always predict 0.
That way, they're
always consistent,
and maybe my loss will
not be looking very pretty
at the boundaries,
but it's fine."
Well, you have a way to prevent
that collapse with two tools.
So one is this prediction
that you get at every step,
is a parameterized function of
weights that we put as design.
So we have it enforced.
And then the second
ingredient in this recipe
is to not backpropagate through
both students, where doing so
could lead to
symmetrical weights
updates that might
not be those that
actually match a fixed target.
So we do that by keeping
one of the students
a slow-moving average and
the other one actually doing
the consistency prediction task.
And when you look at
what results it gets,
it's quite competitive.
And you can do so
in the latent space.
It's called LCM.
You might see in the literature.
But all of these
methods, what they did
is that they focused on
matching a given target.
And one thing that you see
when you have this L2-style
regression loss is that you
have a regression to the mean,
where images don't look as
crisp as you would like.
And GAN solves this.
So let's see if there is
some adversarial objective
that we can introduce
here to make it better.
So before we even do that--
so we were looking
at the sample level,
maybe if we look at things from
a distribution perspective,
we could look at where we could
go in the sample space that
looks where we want to go rather
than a straight single point.
And so the mindset here is
to give a piece of noise
to both the teacher
and student model,
and then based on
the student output,
noise it again and ask the
teacher model, and then a model
that looks like the student
to try to denoise it.
And then use their results to
infer what pieces of advice
the teacher and student models
would give, respectively,
to give the clean image,
and use that signal as a way
to inform what the student
prediction should be.
So we're going to look at this
loss in details in a second.
And you complement
that by ensuring
that the student's
predictions match roughly what
the teacher predictions do.
And we see empirically that this
helps stabilize the training.
So looking at this
distribution loss--
so what you're doing in
practice is the KL divergence
between the distribution of
the fake image with respect
to the real image
based on a fake input.
And when you take the
gradient of it with respect
to the parameters of
the student model,
you get this nice interpretation
of a difference of scores
that you could see as a
difference of velocities
in the field of flow matching.
And these respectively
means that we
want to do more of
what the teacher says
we should do and less of what
the student says we should do.
And we multiply-- we do a dot
product such that the parameter
updates reflects that goal.
OK, great.
Yeah, I want to
pause for one second
just to check if
that makes sense.
Yeah, so here-- so the question
is, What's real and fake?
So here the paper uses
standard denomination
like used in GAN to
denote respectively
teacher and student.
So "real" would be
your true image,
like what generates the true
distribution that you want
to reach.
And then "fake" is corresponding
to the distribution
of the student that we want to
make it as close to the real
ones.
So respectively,
teacher and student.
Yeah, great point.
So the question, Is there
a collapse here happening?
So it might.
So if you were not doing that
comparison between teacher
and student advices, you
would collapse to the mode
of the teacher advice.
And then the paper does
some ablation study on it.
And then the second piece
that I mentioned earlier on,
if you do not regress
with the teacher's output,
you might see another--
not really collapse, but you
would not reach the desired
teacher distribution.
So yeah, the answer
is the collapse
is bad if you were not
considering this setup.
But based on this
setup, I think there
is some hyperparameter tuning
on how to balance the regression
and distribution loss.
Yep.
Awesome.
So moving on-- so I'm going
to make a series of complaints
that are very targeted.
So you're going to
see where I'm going.
So here we're comparing
things with respect
to the teacher output, which
is not the ground truth.
So what I've mentioned here.
So I've hovered over it.
But the teacher--
the student advice
is actually a diffusion
loop that you're running,
which is quite expensive.
And it's a bit of a duplicate
concept with respect
to the student model that you're
training in the first place.
And this idea of providing
signal with respect
to teacher minus student advice
might seem as a soft one.
Is there a way to
reframe it better?
And yes, with GAN-like loss.
So this is what ADD does.
And to be mindful
of your time, I just
want to say the high-level
is that it reframes
as a classification
problem that makes
the problem harder in the sense
that it will lead the student
model to make
predictions crisper.
But the issue with
all of this is
that you have a lot of
back-and-forth going
from the pixel to
the latent space
that later techniques, such
as LADD, tries to mitigate.
And this is what you're
going to be used quite a bit
today, so you can reformulate
that only in latent space.
And just to give some
final words here--
so I want to say that
all of these distillation
techniques-- they offer
some kind of trade-off.
For example,
consistency models--
they might be very
easily tunable
with sets of LoRA weights,
as Afshin mentioned,
whereas, for example if
you go into GAN territory,
you have some dynamics
in the training process
that are hard to manage.
And yet this duality between MSE
and LPIPS loss for regression
happens quite a bit, and
switching the mindset
to a distribution and
GAN-based is great for quality.
And yeah.
And then trends are
these days to do
all of this in latent space.
And that's all I had for you.
Thanks, and have
a great weekend.